ivan chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
c'est en italie en sicile que nous
rencontrons cet empereur à bar du soir
qui n'est autre que charlemagne
nous sommes dans son château il y reçoit
roland puis tous épreuve richement
cuirassé relance avance et prêtent
serment avec son glaive
l'audience va se terminer
l'empereur fait un petit speech et ses
chevaliers cuirassé le quitte avec une
rapidité l'éclair seul l'empereur est le
dernier des pr repart qu'une démarche
spéciale en freinant les genres gratuit
et vous même puis c'est une suite de
combats singuliers
tout se fait sur le même modèle les deux
rivaux arrive sur la scène en vol plané
ils luttent à grands coups de glaives et
fracas d'oublier les marionnettes est à
peu près 75 cm de hauteur
elle pèse une douzaine de kilos il est
pas mal à manier
et parfois où une scène d'amour vient
rompre la monotonie duels les vêtements
sont en tissu de soie ou devenu membre
des doors
les armures sont en métal repoussé d'un
travail très fin le bois même des
marionnettes les vêtements les armures
les décors la mise en scène les
dialogues tout est l'oeuvre d'une seule
famille père et fils les marionnettes
sont animés vous l'avez remarqué par de
grosses tiges de métal et par d'autres
plus fine
toutes sont parfaitement visibles mais
tout compte fait cela ne nuit pas à
l'illusion du mouvement
voici un duel parmi tant d'autres à
gauche le héros bien aimé roland à
droite le roi l'autriche la foule prend
naturellement partie aussitôt pour celui
qu'elle cède avance être le vainqueur
car bien entendu elle connaît toute
l'histoire un grand voit cette fois ci
un roi du mans si ça pense dans les rue
de messines dont le sort du garage où il
est enfermé où ils sont enfermés lui et
sa femme depuis l'an dernier pour les
sortir on doit démonter d'abord le
garage la manoeuvre n'est pas facile car
c'est très lourd mais rassurez vous il y
à des fins de sécurité
la veille le sort d'abord les galas
et c'est le colosse représentent les
fondateurs de la ville de messine
on les promène le fresu dans la moitié
nord de la vigne le 14 vendredi sud
ils sont précédés d'un faux chameau qui
dansent et se dandine comme tous les
prochains jours
cette tradition populaire les deux
géants remonte au moyen-age elle est due
à la rivalité qui existait entre palerme
et messine chacune cherché à voir
l'origine la plus ancienne
alors messina vente 1 le géant et la
géante nuit c'est cham le fils de
nouilles
évidemment on ne pouvait qu'avoir des
plus au cld élus tous les 500 mètres
environ le contexte cerep reprendre
haleine et chamouille posé sur la
chaussée
à ce moment-là fera en place une ronde
endiablée la place de la cathédrale est
en veille le touriste tous les jours à
midi
ils viennent admirer l'horloge
monumentale construite à strasbourg est
inaugurée en 1933 elle est paraît-il la
plus grande du monde et si par malchance
elle tombe en panne ce qui arrive
parfois
les marchands de cap postale mime pour
les touristes mais avec la plus grande
exactitude le coq qui chante le yom qui
rugit l'église avec la colombie qui vole
enfin tout un théâtre ambulant
e
en face de messine sur la côte italienne
se trouve le petit village de sylla de
vieilles maisons collées les unes aux
autres au bord de l'eau si la dhr sa
renommée à un terrible monstre ce
monstre avait site est effroyable à
trois rangées de dents serrées à tous
les amis qui passait près de lui il
prenait un homme dans chacune de ces
gueules
voici le rocher aubéry s'il a pour
l'instant pourrait bien calme au pied du
rocher où l'une monstres affreux
il n'ya que d'inoffensifs pêcheurs à la
ligne celui-ci perchée sur ce match
festive mais monde 8 surveillent les
eaux du détroit
non pas pour trouver six lames plus
simplement l espadon
et avant de monter là où regarder le
faire il fait trois fois le signe de la
croix et récite une prière puis il donne
quatre coups sur le mât cela veut dire
allons réveille-toi fait nous faire une
bonne pêche au sommet ils se tiennent
debout sur une planche il a passé une
fin de série une somme fixée au mas il a
lancé son appel n'est pas pour nous pas
devant cette fois et pour un bon demi le
temps qu'ils passent par là aussitôt
branle bas de combat de tous côtés on se
précipite pour mettre à l'eau le fim est
un mal serré
la panne imad haras à bord de chaque
barque des heures monte en haut du mât
rendez-vous générale de toutes les
barques et grande excitation pour bien
refermer le filet sur le banc de
poissons tout le long de la côte sur 4
kilomètres sont disposés val poste de
guet sous forme d'une brousse barque
trapu solidement ancrée avec un guetteur
chacune de ces grosses barca attaché à
une petite barque rapide avec un
mammouth mois ou cloud sur la petite
barque on si il y à un guetteur dès que
le signal est donné la petite barque se
libère et son buteur long thomas pendant
que le moteur marche à plein de garde
le guetteur dirige les mouvements de la
barque au moyen d'un volant qui est en
communication avec le gouvernail on dit
toujours le filet le cercle se referme
sur le poisson
le bo vient de lancer le signal donné ce
pas dans cette fois la petite vague se
précipite le harponneur va prendre sa
place à la vente tout à fait à
l'extrémité il refait le geste qu'a fait
3 millions avoir lieu au même endroit
ulis près il frappe il a raté son coup
il frappe de nouveau le voit s'en est
échappé le guetteur redescend
le canot revient vers le bord et
s'attache aux bateaux vigie espèce de
passerelles envoyais 3 qui est à chanter
à l'avancé à éviter l'espadon ne voit
l'ombre de la barque se profiler au
dessus de lui
les méfiants et il disparaît facilement
à de grandes profondeurs
alors si cela arrivait bien il n'y a
plus qu'à attendre les courants sont
très forts dans le détroit de messine
ils atteignent 10 km à l'ère des zooms
sont peu profondes elles sont très
puissants forme dont paris tig et on ya
compté jusqu'à 140 différentes espèces
de poissons seul pour les pêcheurs on
profite de cette attente pour boire bien
frais et trempé sont pas dans la
soupière qui bien sûr contient la soupe
comme ça c'est beaucoup plus simple pape
est sale affaire chacun ajuste sa
pochette
pour que les marins ont fait la relève
des terres les hommes changent tout que
trois heures c'est très très fatigant
d'être là où est au bout de trois heures
à force de scruter la mer on ne voit
plus rien
je pensais découvrir sept syllabes
s'élançait du rocher pour prendre mes
hommes j'ai eu beau chercher je ne dis
points et mais je suis fatigué à force
de fouiller la roche embrumé y
définissent les hommes peuvent faire
muguet
seul le patron navire ne monte jamais
l'appel a retenti le nouveau branle bas
de combat
le harponneur est à son poste avec ton
cheval est sur la passerelle les de
harpon ils sont en boîte charmer mesure
promet de 60 de l'eau leur bonheur est
en position il guette l'espadon prête à
frapper dès qu'il a les reins surgir à
fleurs boucle voilà le coup a dû porter
puisqu'il ne relance pas un levier
et voilà ozcan aux états fois son voisin
du temps qui mesure environ deux mètres
et pèse 70 kg lorsqu'il est adulte mais
s'il y en a qui mesurent jusqu'à 5
mètres et pèse 300 kg il s'appelle aussi
poisson et paix parce que sa mâchoire
supérieure est allongé en une immense
point il presque aussi longue que le
reste de son corps est maintenant
regardez regardez ces eaux qui
tourbillonne c'est la fameuse karine qui
remplissaient d'effroi les navigateurs 1
10 ce tourbillon est indiquée par une
spirale sur les cartes maritimes
c'est en fait la rencontre de deux
courants opposés l'un venant de la mer
tyrrhénienne l'autre de la mer ionienne
d'ailleurs même encore de nos jours les
petits bateaux à voile doivent naviguer
dans cet endroit avec une immense
prudence à cause de la rapidité et de la
variation des commandes et maintenant
vous saurez ce que vous dites tomber de
charybde en scylla
hélène chagnon vous a proposé voyagera
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec des films de maxime clairet montage
rené garrisson roger fait et jean-paul
type emploi script marcelo chez
lustration sonore dominic palladini
réalisation solange péters